well good morning it's a
pleasure to be back again giving the dna
hit of the year talk and it's also a
pleasure
to be with thermo fisher's scientific's
hid conference the hits conference where
we give the hit of the year results
every year so thank you very much and i
look forward to a
a great presentation with you folks so
first of all let's keep in mind the
reasons we do the hit of the year every
year one it's to recognize
not just the crime lab folks but also
law enforcement and everyone else in the
criminal justice system
including the policy makers that utilize
dna databases to solve
and prevent crime secondly we use this
program as a way to bring awareness
because we know that
most of the world still does not have
has not passed
dna database legislation or implemented
these programs so through real life
cases
we can bring the awareness to the rest
of the world so they can also utilize
this great tool to solve crime
and we know when we bring this awareness
that it causes policy makers to take
action
not just on the legislation that allows
the offender database programs to exist
but also with the funding necessary to
implement these programs
so 2020 even with all that's going on in
the world
we had 50 cases from 20 countries submit
to the program from those 50 cases
gordon thomas honeywell
took the list studied it and recommended
17 cases to go up to an international
panel
of seven judges the judges then reviewed
those cases
and they ranked them one through 17
independently
we then took the top six from their
ranking completed more research
worked with the judges to study the
cases and then the judges got on an
international conference call
and ranked the cases one through six
with the top cases
case being the one they selected as the
2020
hit of the year let's meet our judges
real quick
we have jody hines from orange county
california
walter parsons from innsbruck austria
ronaldo henry
the crime lab director from the
philippines magdalena the dna director
from poland
mauricio hernandez the crime lab
director from costa rica
and christine sim the dna director
from singapore and also rock harmon a
retired prosecutor
from california usa so
with the 50 cases that were submitted
there were a lot of common themes this
year
uh some of the top ones were familial
searching
genetic genealogy missing persons
and ystr testing so what i'm going to do
for the remainder
of the presentation for about the next
40 so minutes what we're going to
explain is we're going to look at the
cases first
that were not selected in the top six
look at some of the common themes from
those cases
and then save the second half of the
presentation for the top six cases
where we will go into more detail about
each case
so let's kick it off we had uh the first
topic we wanted the common theme from
the cases
was the area of familial searching we
have a couple cases here
we also have a familial searching case
to discuss in our top
six cases but in this case in 1995
in a very uh idyllic town on the coast
of sweden
in billadel sweden we had a rape of an
eight-year-old girl that it was attacked
on a bike ride home from her school she
was dragged in the woods sexually
assaulted
and then in a very injured she walked
back to her home this really shook this
little community
very small community and the the police
in sweden did an extensive investigation
they however the dna never matched like
many countries when the dna doesn't
match in the database they ponder
the idea of doing familial searching is
another step
however their law did not allow that so
they approached the
swedish parliament um and
eventually they decided in late 2018
to allow sweden to be a country that
does familial searching they modeled
their law
on that of the united kingdom that has
done familial searching
very effectively over the years in a
very privacy conscious way
they have a national board that allows
them to
that reviews the cases of which ones get
to be approved for
familial searching and then go all
through the privacy protections that are
necessary
to keep the the privacy issues in check
when they were allowed to turn the
familial searching on when the law went
into effect on january
1 2019 this case was one of the top ones
that was approved by that board
and when as soon as they ran it they got
a candidate list
from the familial search and they were
able to investigate
and arrest the person that committed
this horrific crime
the next case relating to familial
searching
is a case coming to us from 2011 sexual
assault of a woman in dubai
and as you know from the case that dubai
selected submitted last year to hit of
the year that was i believe
chosen the second ranked case they go
very aggressively on dna approaches and
the
and the same occurred in this case they
ran the autosomal dna
mat to the database and there were no
hits
they then did ystr they did mido
they did phenotypic snips nothing worked
and then they did familial searching
and what they thought of doing in this
case what i thought was very unique
is that since they already did ystrs on
the casework sample
they decided to do a layer of ystrs on
the candidate list
produced by the familial search and
there was a match and that elevated it
to the top and they were able to solve
the case
pretty quickly with that so we thought
this was a very unique application
of why str's uh integrating into
familial searching
i'd like to say just a moment for meal
searching and wonder
if we're now at the tipping point of
countries and
states deciding to move forward with
familial searching
as we can see it works quite well when
you don't get a hit in your database
familial
searching is a logical next step and it
can be done effectively with a lot of
privacy controls
as exemplified uh in the united kingdom
and now in sweden and many other places
as well so i wonder
and i think that we are moving forward
to more countries looking at this
as an option as a second step to
searching when they don't get a match
in their database the next set of cases
i want to explain
we entitled the extremism murders and in
this first case
in 2019 there was a murder of a very
popular politician from the left side
of the political spectrum that was very
much disliked by the extremist factions
in germany
and he was assassinated in his home in
hessen germany
and unfortunately there was no evidence
at the crime scene that could be noticed
by the police
but fortunately they do have a wonderful
crime lab there
run by dr harold schneider
and they have a very unique process
there
that that lab and many others in germany
have developed and they call it hot
flaking
the idea is you take the clothes from
the person that
you're looking for the crime scene
evidence from and you take a piece of
tape
and you go around each inch of those
clothes and you try to extract skin
flakes
and they did this over a thousand times
they found a thousand skin flakes
on the murdered politicians clothes and
one actual only one produced a dna full
profile
and one would think that would not
likely be a hit in the database but they
got very lucky
lucky in this case a needle in a
haystack that one
profile they found through that hot
flaking process
mashed in the german dna database
and the person it hit to was a known
member
of the neo-nazi party in germany and
therefore
is now the main suspect in this case
he's been arrested and i believe they're
in trial
and this case is just a testament to the
hard work
of the german crime lab to use that
german-based
system the hot flaking process to solve
this case
the second case i want to mention of
extremism murders is the 2019
sexual assault and murder of a 19 year
old girl
walking through the woods in jerusalem
this case is really though
about speed in 24 hours from the moment
they found that body the crime lab was
able to get the dna
process it run it against the database
get a hit and the police were able to
arrest the suspect
all within 24 hours and this is a
testament
to israel's ability to fund a dna
program that allows them to move that
quickly
to identify these individuals and israel
has
a very uh strong dna database law
that has a high hit rate which allowed
this case to be solved as well
unfortunately when they arrested this
individual he declared that he came into
jerusalem that night
to murder a jewish person therefore
showing the extremism
attentions of this killer
the next topic i want to talk about is
missing persons so in this case
in november of 1970 female remains were
found
in a house fire in rural minnesota
united states
later that month an 18 year old girl at
a university
was declared missing it was 1970 they
didn't have the systems to link these
two cases at the time
so the two mysteries went on
independently
fast forward to 2013 the brother
of the missing university's students
approached his parents who are now
in their 80s and he told them he said i
learned about the united states missing
persons program
and how you can have your dna as the
parents uploaded into it and then if it
matches
human remains we now are able to bring
our sis my sister home
they did that and unfortunately there
were no matches in our
estus database a couple years later 2016
a cold case team in the rural part of
minnesota decided to run the human
remains
in that house fire and when they did
that and they uploaded it to the
national database
there was a match and this these two
mysteries were solved at that moment
this is a great end
to this case but i have to bring up the
questions that a little bit
uh make us wonder whether or not we're
doing the right thing here
why did it take the brother of the
missing daughter of its daughter
to go to his parents and lobby them and
explain to them
about this process of giving your dna to
the united states national dna database
shouldn't we have a program in place
government entity
a program that promotes the missing
person's database
so everybody knows who's missing a loved
one in order
that they're encouraged to upload their
dna secondly
2016 is when they did the remain
testing but that body has been dna has
been available in the missing persons
program united states since the 1990s so
why did it take so long
i think that we have a problem again
that we just do not promote our missing
persons program here in the united
states as much as it should be
and i know this problem is global as
well and to back this up in the united
states with some statistics
currently there are 40 000 identified
human remains
in our medical examiner's offices
throughout the united states
and only thirteen thousand of those
forty thousand have been tested
and uploaded to the national dna
database
furthermore with thinking about these
forty thousand samples where
families are looking for them and then
hundreds of thousands of other
missing persons where there's no human
remains we only have 15
000 families that have uploaded their
dna
to end this that tells me that we simply
do not have the legal infrastructure
the funding and the motivation for
people to take advantage of this program
to identify
human remains i think it's time in the
united states
that we focus on this and that we have
some sort of national institute that
brings all that together
that allows this to happen routinely and
could be a model for the other countries
as well
another missing person's case comes to
us being solved by genetic genealogy
so in idaho united states this case
1979 uh mummified uh human remains that
had been dismembered and chopped up were
found in a lava tube
in rural idaho they take that dna
and they compare it to the national
database and there were no matches
they then decided in 2019 to apply
genetic genealogy
to that case and they got a hit to jet
match and after 2 000 hours
it led them to an 87 year old grandson
of these human remains and when they
interviewed this person
this grandson he had quite the tale to
tell
he said yes my grandfather was not a
good person
he apparently murdered my grandmother
with an axe
and the sheriff declared that he was
looking for him for murder
he also told another tale that the town
folks
in that town put together a vigilante
squad
vigilante squad and they went out and
tracked him down and murdered him and
then he said that this
genealogy test now confirmed
that rumor so now we're going to move
over
to the issue of dna databases and
exonerations
this these cases were submitted the
first thing they submit
i'm listing two however for the sake of
time i'm only going to mention the first
one
so 1976 the sexual assault and murder of
a 15-year-old girl
in flint united kingdom the police
developed two suspects in this
case one was an 18 year old boy who
didn't speak english
um there was a transient and that's his
picture of today
on the right he was interrogated very
aggressively by the police and confessed
to a crime
that he did not commit and spent 20
years in prison
the second suspect they interviewed they
did not have enough evidence
and they didn't convict him so fast
forward to current day
the police and the united kingdom
decided to reopen this case to go after
the second suspect and see if the dna
uh found on with this girl is a match to
the second suspect
and when they did the test they found
three things
one that second suspect was not a match
uh to the dna with the that was found at
the crime scene
secondly it didn't match the person that
spent 20 years behind bars so he got
exonerated and the suspect got
exonerated as well
so this is a great result to get both of
those exonerated but in addition to that
they found the true perpetrator because
he was in the united kingdom database
when they ran that dna
and if just a reminder for those that
don't know the united kingdom has
probably the highest dna hit rate in the
world
because they require everybody convicted
and arrested to go into the database for
a period of time their hit rate hovers
around somewhere between 60
and 70 percent and that's the type of
result you can get when you have that
large of a database policy
in your laws um so this case in the case
beneath it are good examples of getting
people
that are in jail or been in jail
released and exonerated through the use
of dna
but more importantly i believe the
exonerations that happen not just
in these types of cases uh every once in
a while
it's the exoneration that happens due to
dna databases probably on an hourly
basis
throughout this world when police have
these databases
and hit on the right person quickly they
do not
investigate somebody that is innocent
they do not knock on the door
and ask them that they were if they were
involved in a serious crime
crime like a homicide and make that
adrenaline go up in that individual
and be worried until they're cleared
because they find the right person with
the database
they don't have to make these people
feel uncomfortable through those types
of
interrogations and that is how dna
databases
exonerate people daily throughout this
world
so just to mention a couple other cases
here we're not going to go through all
these
but i wanted to mention at least two and
the first one comes to us from poland we
call it the power of proom in poland so
for a 20-year period there were stranger
rapes occurring in czech republic
germany and poland then then the polish
police arrested and convicted somebody
they went into the database and it hit
to the rape in poland and because
of the forward thinking of the european
union with the prove treaty
it also hit those rapes in germany
and czech republic this next case we
call
criminals aren't always smart and in
this case
an individual staked out a jewelry heist
in the united kingdom
and he noticed that that jewelry store
did not have a cctv camera
hooked up so he did a tunnel underneath
the store and unfortunately for him
he made the wrong decision he went the
wrong way in the tunnel and went into
another shop
and when he pulled himself through the
tunnel he touched and that shop did have
a cctv camera and it saw exactly where
he touched the police swabbed right
there
they got dna went into the database and
of course
it's the united kingdom so they got a
match and that's how that case got
solved
so we're now going to move over to the
top
six cases and again the judges went
through
and ranked those cases and here are the
six that they
they they voted on in the end and they
ranked them one through six
and the cases they they ranked were from
washington state
usa california usa brazil
another california usa case france
and china and we will talk about them in
the order in which the judges place them
the first the first one the sixth place
case is the murder
of jane hilton and the exoneration of
ricky davis occurring in el dorado hills
california and for those of you don't
know el dorado hills
is basically a suburb of the city of
sacramento in northern california
so in 1985 jane hilton
was murdered in her home she was stabbed
multiple
times she was bitten in the back and the
police came
and there were three people that lived
with her they talked to them
but there was no other evidence and the
case goes cold
they reopened the case in 1999
and they completed an interrogation of
those three individuals that was the
focus of their investigation
and they focused on connie dahl and
interrogated her
and explained to her that the woman was
bitten in the back
and offered her some sort of immunity
and she therefore
said ricky davis was the one who did it
he stabbed her
i only held her down and bit her in the
back and with that immunity
that was the testimony that she gave and
ricky davis
was convicted this didn't sit well of
course the ricky davis always maintained
his innocence
and the innocence project didn't like
the status of that interrogation and
that confession of
of connie dahl so they took on the case
in addition
they did not take dna in that case so
this innocence project actually focused
with the
sacramento county crime lab and the
prosecutor the new generation of
prosecutor in this case
uh was very uncomfortable with it to
begin with two so he cooperated
and they they focused on the dna from
the nightgown
on the spot where the woman said she bit
right and if they could show that the
dna on that nightgown
didn't match connie dahl they could
discredit her testimony and it would be
a
an ability to show that ricky davis did
not commit this crime
sure enough the dna did not match but
because they
didn't match to anybody in the database
they couldn't show who committed the
crime
they had to delay him getting out of
prison but they did offer him a new
trial
but they didn't want to wait for the
trial to be over to get ricky davis out
of jail
so they decided to pursue genetic
genealogy and sure enough
they got a match to jet match did the
genealogical research
and they hit to this individual
in fact the gen match occurred
in uh december of 2019
but the actual uh hit in the uh the
research the gen
the the genealogy research that took
place just a few months ago
and this is the person that actually
committed the crime and now that they
know who committed the crime
they allowed ricky davis to walk out of
prison on february 13
2020. the fifth place case
is the 1991 sexual assault and murder of
sarah yarbow
in the town of federal way which is a
suburb
of seattle washington which is actually
just up the street from where i'm coming
from you today
as i live in the seattle area so in 1991
uh this 16 year old girl that had a lot
going for her
was murdered on her school grounds and
you can imagine the traumatic
um she was sexually assaulted too the
traumatic
event of that for having her body found
by other students
and just the impact on a school like
that
they had dna from the crime scene but it
never
matched encoders
interesting piece about this case they
actually were the first case to ever do
ystr surname searching and when they did
that they hit to the fuller family
and they thought they had solved this
case because there was a close friend
that was named fuller that was a friend
of the yarborough family
and however upon the autosomal testing
it wasn't him
they tried to go up the relationship
path and identify of other fullers
however the real suspect in this case
his grandfather about 67 years ago fell
out of the fuller family because it was
adopted so it was a dead-end trail
so then in 2019 they did genetic
genealogy and it led them to this
individual and this case has been solved
um i do want to mention though some
things about the database law
here in washington state uh that
controls the database
of offenders in this region um they had
three missed opportunities
and it's just a reminder that the laws
that are passed by your parliaments
or your state legislatures in this case
control
how quickly you can solve a crime and
how long these individuals would be on
the streets perhaps committing more
crime
so in this this case the three misses
that they had based on our faulty laws
one
this individual was convicted of a sex
crime before he murdered sarah
and therefore if the washington state
law would have required parolees to be
in the database
they could have taken his dna and after
he committed the murder they would have
found him right away
secondly this individual was arrested
for a sex crime
but then pled to a lower level sex crime
and the washington state legislature
did not have that sex crime in the
database policy
when that occurred and therefore they
missed them a second time and finally
this guy's brother was a convicted
rapist that was also
in the washington state database and
because washington state government does
not allow
familial searching we missed them a
third time so just a reminder the
policies made
by the politicians are the they decide
who gets
identified for these terrible crimes and
we should look at all of our laws to
determine whether or not
they're set up in a way they can keep
people like this off the street
so just a comment about we've had these
couple of cases in genetic genealogy
we had of course the big cases last year
and the golden state killer
and the very many other cases as well
what's the future
of genetic genealogy in forensics
and i look at ged match and the other
databases that allow police
to catch these criminals it's kind of
like a magic portal
and when it first happened last year and
we saw these cases coming through
i couldn't believe it it was basically
it changed everything the way we think
about solving crime
with dna and it did a lot of work and
these are just some of the individuals
these
cases in the united states that had
never going to be solved that now
because of this magic portal are going
to be solved
i think where we're headed is that
genetic genealogy we've kind of worked
through the backlog of the old cases
that would never be solved
and from now on i think we're going to
see what we'll call a plan b
approach on every new case so if you
have a homicide
a stranger rape other types of assaults
that can't be solved when you
put the dna into the codis database you
go to plan b
which is genetic genealogy and i think
that's just going to integrate itself in
a normal law enforcement practice
and we'll see that plan b on all cases
going for all serious cases
going forward so the fourth place case
is the 2008
murder of a mom and her daughter
in guangzhou china in fact it was in a
very upscale neighborhood in their
high-rise condo where somebody broke in
to commit a property crime
ran into them killed both of them and
left
a single drop of blood behind at the
crime scene
now they took that dna and they put it
into the massive
chinese database as you may know china
has 50
000 criminal offenders or excuse me 50
million
criminal offenders in their database the
largest dna database in the world by far
and again if you don't solve them with
an autosomal hit in that database
china is eventually going to find the
killer because in addition to those
autosomal 50 million database they also
have 10 million folks
that are in the ystr database so again
between the two they're eventually going
to get a lead
and that happened in this case because
in 2019 there was a ystr match between
somebody named june who's an only child
to the killer's ysdr they tried the
autosomals against
june and there was no match so like any
good ystr investigation
what do you do next you go check the
father and the father's brothers and
they did that
and there was no autosomal match but a
curious thing happened they noticed
through kinship testing that the father
and the five uncles were all
half siblings to june and the killer so
this got the investigators thinking
and they kind of figured it out and they
went and got the dna from
june's grandfather and june's mother and
it turns out they produced
a secret child that they put up for
adoption so the police went out
investigated the adoption records
that led them to the true killer that
they lured back to guangzhou
and here the police are arresting him at
the guangzhou airport so this case very
amazing case
a lot of work obviously went into
solving this case
the third place case is a case that came
from woodland california usa
and in 2017 in woodland california
is also by the way it's a suburb of the
san francisco area
and in 2007 excuse me um the remains of
an infant boy
were found in a metal chest and brought
up somebody fishing in a canal
and the boy had been murdered clearly
but because of blunt
force trauma to his skull and they took
the dna
and put in the missing person's database
but there were no matches
in 2018 the sheriff the prosecutor and
the state police
decided they're going to try familial
searching of the human remains
against the offender database in
california
however there is not a process to search
human remains in california familial
searching although there is one
for searching crime scene samples
against
convicted offenders um but they got
permission to do this
and when they did they hit to the
infant's father
that also was actually just three days
from being released from prison
and then we asked they asked him to
identify the child
he wouldn't do it so the investigators
then went and researched all the
children
that he had been recorded as being the
father of in california
and they got the the genetic testing
card from the hospital
and the first case that i'm aware of
they got a court order to take the dna
off the card and compare it to the human
remains
where they determine that this boy his
name is nico
and they were able to determine that
from the the genetic cards that were
maintained
at the hospital but very disturbing
about this case
during the research they also determined
that were four other infants
that have not been heard of since they
were born
and so as a result of that this county
has charged this individual for five
counts of murder
a serial emphasized case that's going on
currently and we're going to hear a lot
more about this case
as it plays out in the court
so that leaves us with two finalist
cases
we have the cases from brazil and the
case from france
so the judges voted and they determined
that the 2020 hit of the year
is the case from brazil and so before i
outline that case and also we're
fortunate
after i speak we're going to hear for a
few minutes from the crime lab and
investigators from the brazilian federal
police
about the case but before i do that i
want to talk to you about the french
case
so this case it's called the little
martyr of the a-10 motorway
in blue is france so this
this little child that you see here in
the picture she was about four years old
was abused and abandoned and thrown in
this ditch where the police officer
is pointing she was clearly abused for
the following reasons one
they found that she had broken bones
that had healed and
reinjured over time she had human bite
marks on her body
she had marks from an iron where she had
been scorched and she had been very
malnourished so this case became
a very important case the people of
france apparently it was the most
investigated case for about 15 or 20
years they really wanted to know who she
was
and where she came from the dna story
goes like this in this case
1993 when dna got its legs
they resumed the body took the dna from
the remains
tested it against the databases and
there is no match
in 2008 they decided to do phenotypic
snips and you can imagine this is before
next generation so it meant that the
thermo fisher scientific
3130 device was chugging away over time
and
eventually cranked out the right snips
to determine
that they were from north american
ancestry
then in 2013 dna technology took another
leap forward
and they were able to do more touch dna
and as a result of that
they were able to fi find a full sibling
dna
on the the deceased child's blanket
and because the french policy allows
them to upload those types of samples to
their database that
probably not from the killer because it
was a young child's dna
into the database this proved to be
the perfect solution of this case
because in 2017
the sibling was convicted of
a crime in france and went into the
french offender database
and therefore matched to the dna that
that person
left on the blanket and as a result of
that they were able to research this
case find the mother
and she has been charged and arrested
for neglect
and murder so that leads us to the 2020
hit of the year which is called by the
media
and brazil and throughout the world
actually is the robbery of the century
and the reason it's called the robbery
of the century
because it's a blockbuster case as
you'll see it
it feels like it's a movie script and it
was committed by the largest criminal
organization in brazil the crime
actually
occurred in ciudad which is in paraguay
and for those of you who have not heard
of this town it's the second largest
city in paraguay it's actually
on the border a river separates it from
brazil
and argentina and it is known to mean
the community
close to the the beautiful iguesu falls
that is apparently the largest
waterfalls in the world
so it is as i mentioned it was committed
by the largest
criminal organization in brazil it is
known as the pcc
it has 20 000 members it's active in 22
of the 27 brazilian states as well as
other south american countries it
focuses on
drug trafficking big time robberies like
this one
and other illicit activities they rule
over the
famous favelas in brazil and as one of
our
judges on our panel this year said it's
from the region
unfortunately strong criminal
organizations
are part of our life in central and
south america
so this was the crime scene this is what
occurred april 24th
2017 the target was 40 million us
dollars
that was stashed inside of the
progressors
uh cash transit facilities office in
this town
and over 50 heavily armed assailants
prepared at a staging house in paraguay
they then crossed into paraguay in a
military style raid
they blew up the building they grabbed
the vaults
took as much money as they could and
then created a path of destruction as
they worked their way back into brazil
that ended with a three-hour shootout
with the brazilian federal police
so here are the crime scenes in the case
we had
uh we have the paraguay staging house
where the 50 people uh staged the crime
we have the
bomb blast of the presager site and we
had the shootout
with the brazilian police from those
three crime scenes
the brazilian federal police collected
457
pieces of evidence and from that they
had touched dna from abandoned escape
boats and vehicles
they had dna throughout the staging
house on bedding
on plates things like this they had dna
from weapons and explosives
left at the at the uh the bomb sites and
they had blood from the bullet wounds
from the shootout with the police they
also had
three suspects that died in the shootout
they had their dna
that got uploaded and they had seven
suspects that got captured at the
shootout they had their dna
and it got uploaded so in the end the
brazilian brazilian federal police crime
lab
were able to find from these 457 pieces
of evidence
47 full profiles that they put into
their database in addition
11 suspects that also went into the
database and just give you a little bit
of background about the brazilian
coda system it's the second largest
installation of codis behind the united
states
they have 20 state network that upload
to a national
dna database the brazil federal police
but the dna database in brazil is quite
new in fact it just
started to move forward just a couple
years ago because of a decision by the
government of brazil to make dna testing
in its database the top priority
to fight crime in brazil but since it
just started it only has 70 000
criminals in the database however
we predict in the next five years brazil
will probably be one of the top five
databases
size wise in the world
so the 47 crime scene samples and 11
fenders got uploaded in the database and
here were the hits that occurred as a
result of that
first nine and 11 suspect matched to the
crime scene so that from the shootout
they were able to because they met they
took the dna they met they compared it
to the
found at the staging house and at the
bomb blast and therefore
they were able to place these suspects
at that crime scene
secondly 14 of the 47 crime scene
profiles
linked to other serious crimes and there
were big serious crimes that were
conducted by this gang
just a couple of examples there was a
murder of a federal agent that it linked
to
another one was a 28 million similar
heist of a brink's car company
facility and in addition to that
as i mentioned excuse me um in addition
to that
uh there were matches to offenders
however because this is a new database
there's only 70 000 people in it you
weren't going to have a lot of hits of
these 47
profiles in the beginning it's about the
future in this case
and that's exactly what happened there
wasn't any instant matches
to offenders in the database when they
put these 47 in they came later and
they'll continue to come
and this is exactly what happened in
june of 18
one of the people at the crime scene
matched when they got convicted and put
in the database
it happened again in march of 19 again
in july of 19
again in march of just a couple months
ago march of 2020.
so again this is about the future with
this case
they have 13 identifications so far
there's 34 to go and because of the
investment
by the brazilian government to build
this database our guests
is that most of these 47 people that
were at those crime scenes
are going to hit the database over time
so i think the judges in this case they
voted it number one for a number of
reasons
first of all the blockbuster nature of
it and secondly
the hard work of the brazilian police
crime lab i mean they have 400 plus
samples they had to work through uh and
under very difficult circumstances was
amazing work
third is we talked about the future of
the dna database program in brazil
and the recognition of the government to
make it a strong program and finally
what dna can do to take a bite out of
these criminal organizations so those
four things combined
are the reason they ranked it uh the
number one case
so before we hand it over to our friends
in brazil
that were selected as the number one
case
i do want to make some acknowledgments
of course everybody from the brazil
federal police
secondly is our dna hit of the year
judges they did a wonderful job
reviewing these cases we know it's a lot
of work so thank you very much
judges and kyle schroeder and hannah
jones from gordon thomas honeywell did a
lot of work as well
to put this program together this year
and finally thermo fisher scientific
thank you so much you folks sponsor this
program every year we couldn't do it
without you
and thank you for allowing us to explain
these cases and the selection by the
judges
at your annual kids conference so with
that
i'll hand it over to the brazil folks
thank you very much
the robbery of the century a big fabric
is
the biggest one in the forensic dna lab
of the brazilian federal police
and now it is the dna heat of the year
2020.
this is so important to us and it was
such an honor working on this case
gathering all the data and having the
opportunity to show it to you
that's i'm here in english because i
want to address
directly to first change childbirth in
behalf of whom i thank
the gordon thomas hanwell group for
sponsoring the dna heads of the year
program
thank you kyle schroeder for your
patience and real interest
in understanding all the details of this
case
with so many profiles crime scenes
links i know it was a little bit tricky
sometimes
i want to thank all the judges for
recognizing our hard work on this case
we are so many involved federal and
states
forensic dna experts csi experts and
criminal investigators
this award is a big push for us to keep
going and growing proudly
and thanks tamara fisher for always
being a partner
and having us here at his virtual
conference
foreign
foreign
[Music]
be
foreign
[Music]
foreign
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
well what actually amazing work uh tim
thanks for uh putting together the heat
of the year
once more and obviously thank you very
much to the selected
uh case in brazil
while we wait uh to close the session we
can also take a few questions so please
don't hesitate
to use the q a chat in your in your
browser to ask questions to team
team maybe you want to say something
worse to close the session
sure um thank you all for uh
participating today
um because of the transition to the
brazilian folks so we weren't able to
actually do the introductions ahead of
time so i just want to let the audience
know
who those three people were the first
one was anna de castro
she's a forensic expert in the brazil
federal police
the second speaker there was ronaldo da
silva who is
runs the national database as their
administrator
and finally was emerson rodriguez who
was actually the head
of the investigation from the brazil
federal police so
uh it was a pleasure uh working with
them
and um letting them know that they were
selected as the dna hit of the year and
uh
obviously for that case you can see they
did a a wonderful job
so with that and um we
uh are just very pleased that we were
able to participate again this year
and um hope the audience enjoyed it
thanks tim um there are some questions
coming through the chat i mean there is
a question from moscow about
if there is any any publications about
these cases or maybe some of them or how
they can get
these information sure so um
this presentation will be available
online of course but in addition to that
if you go to
the dna hit of the year website which
can be found by going to dnaresource.com
hit on the 2020 dna hit of the year
program and you can see the actual
submissions from the countries
of the cases which gives you in most
cases about three or four written pages
of work about the cases media links
things like this
so that could be be a good resource for
them
okay so
um if there are no more questions we are
not coming to the chat i think that we
can close this one again
thank you very much tim for putting this
together for the presentation this
morning i know it's early for you
and also thank you obviously for all
those that contributed to the heat of
the year
once more and see us next hit
next hits in 2021 so um we are going to
close this session
and basically remind you that the the
the live session continue later after
the break so we have something like 25
minutes now
so and if you come back at 1 15 central
european time or 12 15 uk time
we are going to start with the regional
sessions remember that there are two
options for you you have the english
session with the speakers
in in english uh and there is the arabic
session where
where there is going to be driven by dr
rashid from dubai police
and there is that is the arabic session
uh mostly of it is in arabic
thank you very much see you soon thanks
tim
bye